hey rich and adam this is tanya from
lucerne filterlin
i would love to hear your thoughts on
this topic so
i've been living plant-based for over
five years i try to mostly buy things
secondhand
i always stop to question if what i want
to buy something that i really need
and i do this partly because i'm really
concerned for our planet's future and
its resources but also
because i have a one-year-old kid and i
really want him to grow up living
consciously and making deliberate
choices
so i try really hard to remind myself
that
i'm in control only of myself i often
struggle with older people
from other generations who live very
frivolously
with like seemingly little concern about
the impact
they're having on the planet i know that
grandparents can have
a massive influence on their
grandchildren so have you found
good talking points to address this or
do you just
try to not think about it too much and
let people live how they want to
thanks so much tanya from lucerne
yes lucian in the house isn't that where
they make the butter
is that where they make the butt is it
shout out lucerne so
um thanks for your question this is
tricky
uh i think it's important to
of course make the best choices that are
in line in alignment with your values
and that's what tanya's doing
she's conscientious about her needs and
her wants and
tries to make sure that her consumer
choices
are in alignment with her values and
that's something to be
celebrated and certainly that's healthy
modeling for
your child because it's not about what
you say it's about
um it's about what you do it's about
your behavior
but i also think this question has a lot
to do with controlling the controllables
understanding what you can control and
what you can't control and really
having a healthy mindset around how you
calibrate all of that as a parent you
lead by example in action
again you model this behavior for your
kids but it's also important to
not be a martyr especially if you're
if part of your interest is in trying to
inspire the next generation if you're
suffering then that doesn't become
an aspirational way to live your life
and ultimately
that's going to set you set you up for
your kid to just rebel saying i don't
want to live
my life like that that doesn't look like
any fun right i want to thrive and
you know why was i deprived of all these
things i'm going to go out into the
world and get them like kids are always
going to differentiate in that way and
they're going to want to explore
the opposite of what they've been
presented with so you have to be mindful
about that a little bit and i think it's
important to not overly
in an unhealthy way attach to how your
child's moral compass will evolve and i
say that as
a parent of four and two teenagers right
now like i've experienced a variety of
permutations on this
everything from we love the way that you
parented us and we want to model our own
value system based upon how we were
raised to
i don't want anything to do with this
keep that vegan
get that vegan butter out of here and a
lot of that just has to do with how they
come out of the womb
you know what i mean like but my point
being that the only
block chain you only have so much
control over these things right yeah
exactly the ultimate blockchain
um and i guess i would also say that i
can appreciate how it can
at times feel dispiriting that um
perhaps you feel like you're not making
enough of a difference like you make
these small choices in your life but how
much is this really
moving the needle um
but i do think they hold symbolic power
and they do model for other people
in your orbit like what's important to
you and
it sends the message out that this is
something of value to you and perhaps
would be
of value to other people but
because there's so little we can control
in the kind of
climate trajectory of our planet there
are other ways that you can contribute
through activism or charity or
organizing
because ultimately the real change the
big change
is going to have to be systemic and
that's going to come through legislative
and regulatory changes
not by a few isolated people sacrificing
all of their happiness and well-being on
the altar of like martyred
sacrifice so i think it's important to
to reframe uh
when thinking about all this to to
reframe
how you approach the mindset of your
parents i assume your parents your
child's grandparents
um this idea that you're going to change
their minds or that i think it's in luck
is it in laws
we don't know we don't know what's going
on in lucerne no
is it butter or in-laws i think it's
in-laws
um you know that's you're setting
yourself up for
for a losing battle there like these
people are set in their ways it's very
unlikely that you're gonna
get them to see things differently and
and you don't want to leave yourself
you know frustrated and
irreparably eroding a relationship that
is perhaps healthy
in other ways i think that you have the
opportunity as your child gets older to
contextualize you know where your
grandparents are coming from and their
life experience
you know for your child as he gets older
but in the meantime
you know all i have is like my own kind
of approach to all of this which is
less about being in the business of
trying to change other people's minds
and more about just being
a lighthouse like if you could just be a
beacon of positive energy
and positive change and living your life
in accordance with your values
that's much more attractive and i also
think magnetic and powerful
than bitching about how other people you
know don't get it
no doubt you have in-laws i have i i
literally
started really i don't really i haven't
i i my
uh my wife is like jason bourne she
comes from nowhere
really interesting um she's got she's
got a past
um so no we're not really super we do
have i do have in-laws but it's not like
it's a close thing they're all
in australia and um but she has in-laws
i'll tell you that
my wife hasn't lost right so maybe she
should be sitting here
no um you know i
i think and she's vegan but you know
it's different like my
my parents aren't trying to um yet uh
feed
you know he's obviously still nursing
and he's just getting into
people food and um and so
at some point he'll be spoiled with ice
cream and things that she won't feed him
in that exact way i'm sure um
but that's not really on our on our
plate i think this is interesting i
think you made a really good point in
that
um all the people i know involved in
environmental activism from
a consumer perspective like the marine
plastic pollution
people like the real professionals five
gyres and other organizations like that
they will tell you the fight is upstream
it's not about you know learning how to
do everything
with reusable it's not about like you
can't
erase all plastic from your life it's
about stopping the production
of future plastic stopping those plastic
plants exactly like
you were saying the fight the changing
of the world is upstream
it's not necessarily in your daily life
now on the other hand
i could see how having a certain ethos
is a lifestyle and of itself
and it can actually be a confidence
booster for you
but you're flagging that it could also
be repellent for the child as the child
grows child's one years old
right it's not a problem yet but like
more will be revealed more will be
revealed but i think those are all
interesting points and great points and
uh
you know the boomers are the boomers
right what are you gonna do
boomer's gonna boom boom boom
[Music]
[Music]
you